if anybody ever threw up not here
do you feel like you might
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today i'm joined
by the legend trick daddy dollars
he's a platinum selling artist with more
than 20 years in the rap game a bona
fide hit maker and arguably hip-hop's
greatest chef
trick daddy welcome to the show it's
long overdue he appreciates
him and then i know that you love your
cajun spices how do you think you'll do
today against the wings of death
i can do the spice thing but not on the
mexican side like because the mexicans
got some
different level of hot stuff well we
have some different level hot stuff too
you ready get it going
let's go
[Music]
okay
let's play play
so there are a lot of rappers who get
credit for their cooking skills be it
action bronson
coolio master p but the real ones know
that trick daddy is the bobby flay in
hip hop
your instagram stories it's basically
the best food show
on the internet kosher macaroni and
cheese
looking good step over here to the stove
got the lima beans and [ __ ] i got my
pots
i'm a gichi geechee meanie my family is
from
south east south carolina closed by the
waters
and being that i was the second oldest
of 11 i
ended up not washing dishes or cleaning
up this more
but doing the cooking as somebody who
now works with a certain level of
swagger around the stove what are your
kitchen pet peeves when someone else
steps into your kitchen
i don't know if i want you to know the
little special
thing that i put in my shrimp and grits
my main thing is if you're in my kitchen
you got to be a fine girl or you got to
be my assistant
and you cutting up onions and bell
peppers why was your neighborhood
growing up called pork and beans
it was called the polka beans because
the color of the door was the same color
the polka bean cans it was really the
liberty square housing project
and then you have an excellent array of
aprons which one's your favorite
my favorite apron is my apron i got made
that said [ __ ] i got my pots
[Music]
everybody know about this one in the
south
[Music]
even those feel like you added something
else on here
a little spicier than you're expecting
yeah so when an og like you sits down in
the seat
there's way too much to cover over just
a short meal so if you'll humor me i'll
just hit you with some burning questions
that i've always been dying to ask you
the shut up marching band beat is one of
the greatest slappers in history
what's the story behind that
instrumental the story behind the
instrumental is
the two high schools that i use are the
most known high schools in the state of
florida
miami jackson generals and miami
northwestern bulls and you went to
northwestern
i did actually i supposed to win the
northwestern i got in a little trouble
and i had to move back down south where
i went to south bridge
everybody stayed doing half time to see
what
new popular songs that the bands was
gonna do and so i got those two schools
together in historical orange bowl
and shot this video weeks before the
orange bowl was
condemned and then you know slip and
slide records it always struck me as
such a whimsical name for such a thugged
out label what's the story behind how
the name came to be
certain slaves in miami like snitches
get stitches and
and slippers count slipper slide records
just stand for if you slip we gonna
slide
and then improve because when they first
did it touche had a man with a jacket on
like like this like it was fuki
i mean it was real fool what do you have
against bugle boy jeans
booby boy jeans was more like for the
preppy guys would you wear polos
i was rocking polo real real big one
time
and then polo actually it's crazy
because i sent one of the secretaries
i was like i need you to get me a pr
person get in contact with polo
i don't want them to pay me they don't
have to endorse me but all i want them
to do is
let me be able to order things that
nobody else don't have but they don't
have in stores
polo responded no thank you and we we
appreciate it if you didn't even mention
our name or something today instead
how'd you take that i wrote a news um
verse for the next album and i was like
i used to be a polo kid until i thought
all the other stupid [ __ ] that i did
nothing i took personal because i never
asked them to pay me to wear their
clothes anyway but if they go back to
the numbers
when i was talking about this their
stocks went up big time
let's get harder harder that's how the
show's designed
[Music]
so your album thug.com came out in 1998
and according to the pew research center
barely 40 percent of the adult
population was even online back then
and the aol homepage was just a
collection of hyperlinks
do you feel like you were ahead of your
time with that title i feel like
i feel like we slipped
you [ __ ] up i we were supposed to make
some of the internet money we thought
they made some
some facebook money or some myspace
money at the time some of that google
money
i went to prison at a young age we
watched as the prison system changed
and we went from cash in prison to
using our id card as the cash
because you were online before most
people were online right
it put a lot of knowledge in my head
well this is where we gonna be
in years to come has the internet been
good for rap or bad for rap
both so the rap game is so crowded and
so congested now
everybody want to sound it like nobody
got a different style nobody got no
story
my music is totally different from that
a lot of my music is visions
there.com will let them know that i was
a thug for the future
because all the stuff that i talked
about in that album still
is happening right now today
you actually good
whoever cut the chicken or to cook the
chicken so i want to stay on the subject
of food because
the trick daddy world it doesn't end in
the kitchen
can you explain the hip-hop world's love
for benihana
i always tell girls the reason why i'm
being honest
is popular in my in my world i always
tell a girl this
if i meet a girl be like what's up baby
check this out i want to take you out to
dinner
can i take you out to a nice restaurant
somewhere where they fix the food right
in front of you
and she be like what benihana's i'm like
no subway
he's so so from there there's just
something about being able to sit down
and cook the food in front of you i know
that you flirted with the idea of
opening a restaurant here in miami
can you close your eyes and describe in
vivid detail what the trick daddy
restaurant looks like
trick daddy restaurants called t-double
delicious
not too many tables because i want you
to get it and go i got collard greens
with ham hawks pigtail and smoked neck
balls in there
macaroni and cheese definitely my drinks
are what you might call in your hometown
arnold palmer
yeah we call the flop here it's called
the flop here it's lemonade with the tea
the the five dollar po man meal what's
in the five dollar poor man meal you get
your three
wings in the fries a cheeseburger to fry
a hamburger a frying
soda or a hot dog or frying a soda or a
hot dog or soda and some chips
and i would have special rate for all
school teachers because i never think
that school teachers
i just don't think that they get paid
when they should get paid
[Music]
hamilton
ah damn
all right trick daddy well we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where we do a deep
dive on our guests instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
so i'll bust out the laptop i'll show
you the picture and then you just tell
me the bigger story does that sound good
okay
here we have a throwback pick with dj
khaled
when you were running around the 305
with dj khaled before he was famous did
you see the dj khaled of today
the same person high energy
very very influential very supportive
if something costs five dollars he'll
make you think it costs five
million dollars while telling you the
cost of five dollars
i do a toy drive every year i did it for
17 years
dj khaled and pitbull are the only two
constant people that donate to trade
love the kids foundation
and make sure the kids have christmas
and back-to-school
programs that i do every year for 17
years so
people always got something to say about
dj khaled bad it's the ones that got
records that's not good enough for him
to play
best party ever with scottie pippen and
lil wayne me scottie pittman lil wayne
all got the same birthday
really yeah that club live the best club
in the world
and they've always shown me love and
this was actually a time
that it was supposed to be some type of
feud between me and baby at the time and
man wayne wasn't even supposed to be
speaking
and it was historical that's one of my
best birthdays in the last 20.
everything was good the women were
looking good and delicious so everything
came out all right
sounds like a hell of a birthday party
you ready to move on trick daddy yeah
unfortunately my nose was starting to
tinker a little
[Music]
it said gluten-free when i first read it
i thought they was giving away gluten
you want gluten it's free here
[Music]
oh god so you hail from miami's liberty
city it's a neighborhood on the north
side that's produced more than its fair
share of college football standouts and
nfl superstars
the u's football program it was so
closely connected to miami's hip-hop
scene at the time
what role did trick daddy play in all
that where were you in that cloth
i'm sure i could say this without nobody
getting in trouble
i endorsed a lot of them took care of a
lot of them and i made a lot of money
off of them
and we played another team from another
city another state come to bring the bag
we've been in the house do you have any
crazy jeremy shocky stories that you can
share with us
yeah but i would that's my main man
me and jeremy shockey we had some nice
times together i imagine i imagine
one story we went to the uh when the
models opened the baseball stadium and
we went down to the clevelander
to the club in there there was some bad
girls in the pool
man uh german shocky he was talking
about the boys from the sixth floor the
song
that dorm rap song the dorm rap song
with uh with greg olsen
right yeah me and shaw was talking about
that did you like that song
i loved it and i think she read he had
the hardest verse out there too g-rag
the girls give me a hat yeah yeah that
one right there
and then we was talking about that song
laughing and we got some ones and we
made it rain on the girls in the pool
and
the owner of the marlin stadium was like
you can't do that in here
like okay okay okay who's a bigger miami
heat fan you're lil wayne
that's a crazy question i'm miami
everything
it's miami against everybody i'm miami
everything
you can't melt louie and palm on me in a
miami heat jersey
sauce mcginty i know
this side of my jaw
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is actually got a nice flavor
this is got just like i got peppers in
it so you're one of the more enduring
icons of miami rap and as we've talked
about today you're always repping 305 to
the fullest so i'd be remiss if i didn't
get a trick daddy city guide from you
what are your tips for having the best
spring break in miami
having the best spring break in miami
all the fellas enjoy the beaches but
don't fall in love with my [ __ ]
don't come down here and act like you
ain't got good sense because
you know the original saying by miami
come on vacation
leave on probation arrive alive
and make sure you come on this side of
the bridge before you can say i've been
to miami
what makes miami strip clubs different
from other strip clubs we get bucket
naked they get bucket naked
they get butt naked in miami is there an
underrated food specialty that you can
push me towards
you need to try cunk and a lot of people
say coke is
aphrodisiac is that that's incorrect
that's a mind thing there's a piston of
the cup
the piston which they say is the penis
but you have to get that straight out
the shell with the kung
if you don't it's not a aphrodisiac but
kung is a
delicatessen here now cup is 15
16 a pound matter of fact i got some in
the trunk right now
when they bought a case of [ __ ] valuable
cargo are you ready to move on
i know one thing the water make it worse
well if you say it it's the truth
okay
so this one is a bomb yeah it is
yes it is god damn
this here yeah
watch your eyes
this is illegal yeah
god damn going for the water even though
you say it makes it worse
[Applause]
we're in the hole so in recent years
you've been pretty vocal about your
opinions regarding the state of rap
what's one way that rap has changed for
the better over the last 20 years and
one way that it's changed for the worse
the way to change for the worst is
nowadays
they either sound alike or they saying
the same thing on every song
they still listen oh my god yeah
[Music]
my eyes watery you look great you look
great
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
man this you don't i mean
let me tell you something yeah yeah yeah
yeah hit me this one here yeah
the next person you take on here don't
don't do this one
find another one i think that's good
advice i don't think this is a
wing sauce i think somebody made this
for me
you think this is all an elaborate prank
on trick daddy man
[Music]
i don't know if the scratch uh out of
the cry
you've said that you appreciate this new
generation of rappers in that they've
solidified your place as the last of a
dying breed what did you mean by that
i respect them
because they showed me how important i
was
to music what's your take on stitches do
you take him seriously as a miami rapper
man stitches we cool and for music i
only do music with people who
are in my label because everybody i know
want to be a rapper now
so if they think oh cause i speak cause
tricks speak to me we cool
hey let me get a feature it's not that
easy i didn't have it that easy you
shouldn't have it at easy
what about kodak black free kodak black
i hope that he can get his head again
and get some people around him that
really care about him
and so he can get him some money because
there's a lot of money in the game for
him because he's young right now
and the young people are the ones that's
buying the records all right trick
this next one is mad dog 357 with number
nine plutonium
lord please help
have anybody ever threw up not here
do you feel like you might have a
garbage with you because i know you gave
me some almond milk
right well we do have this big can here
if it hits you all right it should be
big enough
so as we've touched on a bit today you
have some old school sensibilities
especially when it comes to hip hop but
you also seem like a guy
who can change with the time so what i
want to do is bounce some societal
trends off of you that are bubbling up
in 2018
i just want the trick daddy snap
reaction does that sound good okay
what are your opinions of self-driving
cars like would you trust
a self-driving chevy caprice no way
possible
the car is too heavy it's not going to
stop when you want it
when you want to i'm going to have my
i'm going to have to have me some
invisible gas and brake pedals because
i'm going to be studying pressing gas
and brakes
i just i don't trust no no no car to
just stop on his own
because all computers malfunction do you
think instagram needs to free the nipple
definitely my my thing is
i think that if women are willing to
bear it all on instagram i think it
should be an instagram
x and i think they need to make me the
ceo of it
all the women that want to show their
body and bear it all i don't think their
pages need to be
blocked hacked or not as well as
facebook and then eating ass has really
picked up steam over the last couple
years and i know that you've been the
general of eat a booty gang for years
long before it was trendy
do you still get down like that or has
it lost a little bit of its charm now
that everyone's jumping on the bandwagon
well
i don't know when the last time you
actually bucked the girl up
or uh bend her over to either eat her
uh her vagina but
there's about this much room that
separates that from the ass
it's just it's matters
it's courteous it is it's like being
raised right when you walk in somebody's
house your mama taught you
speak just come by
you eating the [ __ ] oh how you doing
miss miss parker
that's how i came about and i noticed
the reaction of the girls
it's like the birds and bees speech that
my dad never gave me but
should have alright trick daddy
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
did you make this up let's be honest
with you yeah yeah yeah i'll always be
honest with you
okay so i'm not the only one that's
gonna put a little
look look i got [ __ ] on there yeah
there's there's [ __ ] on there already
there's [ __ ] on there already
but you don't have to if you don't want
to
ain't nobody ain't no way god ain't
brought me this far
it dropped me off right here respect
respect
yeah baby
the old peel and eat oh my god
it tastes like the middle of a pebble
[Music]
oh how you doing me [ __ ]
just crazy all right trick daddy here we
are at the top of spice mountain
legs shaky exhausted mouths on fire
and you're a person who's always said it
how you think it
told it how you lived it so i just have
one more
question for you because we all need to
know does trick daddy
still love the kids if the children are
our future
don't they deserve to have they laughed
don't they deserve to have
pictures nobody have photo albums no
more than kids
a lot of my concerts i'd be like i got a
hundred dollars for the first girl who
showed me their kid on a screensaver
i always tell them that the kids of our
future and we have to pay attention to
our kids
not trying to be their friends no
staying up late
they be able to grab their phone and go
in it anytime they want to
be able to walk in their classroom and
check with their teacher anytime they
want to
be able to whoop their ass like we got
our ass with
those old ass whooping days need to come
back into play
and i think the world would be a better
place
from your lips to god's ears you heard
it here first
and look at you trick daddy all the way
through the gauntlet
taking out wings taking out sauces and
didn't even puke in the industrial-sized
garbage can
and that i respect my dude and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
i am the daddy dollars the done daughter
of the dunk rider
the ceo and president of the heaty booty
game the 305 representative
y'all make sure y'all look out for
season two eleven hip-hop miami
the new album trick and trena tnt
in store very soon and ask your sister
about me and ladies
stop telling your kids that i am their
uncle
i'm actually uncle step daddy i love you
how do you feel ah man [ __ ]
hey man that [ __ ] don't make no sense
man this [ __ ] right here man
that [ __ ] started everything right yeah
the bomb
what yeah just like there's a polaroid
yeah bringing it back hey what's going
on hot ones fans it's shawn evans and
you know what
i'm not going to beg for your
subscription if you're not subscribed
turn off the video it's over i want just
my subscribers
come here come here if you're subscribed
to first we feast
i just want to say thank you and then i
appreciate you
that i love you and i hope that you have
a great day